The other way that, that we can do
certain types of understanding what's
going on in the brain is with what's
called physiological measurements.
And so again using animals, typically,
what you'll have is you'll have a screen
where certain display,
certain things are being displayed.
An animal whose head is restrained so
it's looking at a particular direction.
And there's actually an electrode
recording from the neurons in the brain.
You hook that up to an amplifier.
In the old days, you'd look at it
on oscilloscope, and actually,
you'd just connect it to a speaker and
you'd listen.
And more clicks meant you
were getting more response,
and you have to write it down,
and report it.
Then you'd have an oscilloscope
with traces, now of course,
it's all computerized, all right?
You've seen this picture before, this
is a picture of what it looks like for
a microelectrode to be
recording from a neuron.
And up on top, this is what the actual
voltages look like, these spikes.
And so then down here,
you have something that just sort of
counts the, the spikes that go across.
So one of the first areas that people
want to look is what was called V1.
Back in to old days, it was actually
called area 17, I think, but
that sounded too much like UFOs or
something.
I don't know.
It's V1, the first visual area.
And when you record from
the first visual area, and
here's an example, the way you get
a monkey to look at a particular place
is you give him juice whenever he
pushes a button when something happens.
And he, so he'll attend very carefully
there, and it, and it happens,
he pushes the right button,
he gets juice, and apparently,
monkeys really like apple juice.
But while you're doing that, you're
doing other things to the visual field.
And one of the things they've
found is that there are cells
that if you put up a bar,
if you put the bar,
let's say horizontally,
you get hardly any reaction at all.
In fact, put it up at a 45 degree,
still hardly re, any reaction.
Put it up vertically in this case,
and you get a tremendous amount.
And by the way, again,
this is the part where it's off.
This is the part where it's on.
This is the part where it's off.
Now, for this particular trace, I don't
know if the bar was moving at all,
or just being flashed up there.
The movement I'll,
I'll show you in just a minute.
But the idea is that within V1,
the first visual area of cortex, there
are cells that are extremely sensitive
to the orientation of essentially edges.
Remember, we did
oriented edge detection?
So this feels an awful lot
like oriented edge detection.
It would be an oversimplification
to say that's what it's doing, but
it's related.
If you recall,
we also talked about motion.
Well, it turns out in V1, you also get
directional selectivity, all right?
So here, we have a cell, and these,
of course, are the spike trains.
And this particular cell, if you have
a bar that's almost, that's tilted just
a little bit and moving upwards,
you get a small amount of motion.
If you have a bar that's here
on this 45 degree angle and
you moved it upwards,
you got a lot of spikes.
What's remarkable is when you move it
down, you got no spikes at all, or
even less than resting state spikes.
So not only do we have
orientation selectivity,
we have movement selectivity.
And you can actually make a pretty
cool plot of how this distributes
in the brain.
And so this is, this is essentially,
I guess this is your brain on drugs
because, I don't know,
anyway, it's all colored.
But the idea is that each
of these colors represents
these different orientations.
And you can get these mappings, and
you can see that it's not randomly
scattered individual points.
There are regions, all right?
And in fact,
these were referred to as hyper columns
in the sense of that little tissue
areas within the brain will all be
associated with a particular movement.
Now remember, it was retina topic.
So this area is all up on
one part of the retina.
Sure, but within that area, there'll
be little sub parts that are for
verticals and oriented edges like that,
including different kinds of motion.
So those were the kinds of things that
people saw in these first visual areas.
There was a group of neuro-physiologists
Hubel and Wiesel at Harvard,
who I think they worked in,
in cats originally, where they first
looked at these some of these cells.
They also look at a thing called XY
cells having a steady state in motion,
and they won the Nobel Prize for
this work, okay?
So this idea of trying to understand
how the visual cortex was
processing the visual
signal was really in fact,
that Nobel Prize was announced during,
when I was in grad school.
So it was in the 80s at some point.
So that gives you an idea of sort of
the recency of some of this work.